quien tiene uno de los metros más
impresionantes de europa con una
herencia típica de la era soviética es
un lugar lleno de arte e historia pero
desde hace unos días el refugio de
muchos ciudadanos que buscan protegerse
de los misiles rusos porque van al metro
de costa porque la federación rusa
inició una guerra en ucrania que planean
hacer o salvar nuestras vidas
[Música]
allá adentro
espero que nos salvemos porque el metro
de subterráneo
en y que lleva neil a nuestro gato las
horas pasan más lento a decenas de
metros bajo tierra todos están a la
espera de que el conflicto termine para
volver a sus hogares aunque no son
víctimas de las bajas temperaturas la
escasez de alimentos y la falta de un
lugar cómodo para dormir han hecho más
complicada la estadía luego de que el
presidente ruso vladimir putin anunciara
la operación militar las fuerzas rusas
empezaron a lanzar varios misiles cerca
de kiev en la noche del 23 de febrero al
siguiente día el alcalde de la capital
detuvo el transporte público para que
las estaciones de metro pudieran usarse
como refugio las 24 horas
las explosiones se siguieron escuchando
por lo que las alarmas antiaéreas
sonaron en toda la ciudad para pedir a
los ciudadanos que no salgan de sus
hogares o refugios
[Música]